when you're ready to talk you talk I
never let nobody make you be quiet you
stop being a father who is not just
father but an african-american father I
feel like that role had to like tug at
your heartstrings and kind of feel
surreal what was it like taking on that
role where you had to sit down and tell
your children what they might experience
when it comes to police officers they
always talk about you not necessarily
being ready for robot a role being ready
you know for you and where you are in
your life I realized that actually I
could have played that role you know
four or five you know 10 years ago but
spiritually I was not ready and it took
you know the fact that I do have kids
and I do I have two boys three and one
now and being a father changes things
being a father changes your approach to
the work it changes your your your
passion for the material but also
changes where you are spiritually and
you just did that they hate you give
little infants everybody there's a lot
of Oscars buzz for you to be nominated
for this role in maverick what would
your reaction be if you were to take
home a nomination let alone a win for
you know I be over the moon you know I
can't you know I'd be lying if I said
it's not something I had you hadn't
dreamed about you know or I have but but
the truth is it's really always been
about the work for me and you know I
come from the theater but we're by the
work of August Wilson and so it has just
always been about the opportunity to
tell good stories and be a part of good
narratives but you can't lie to me and
say you don't have a speech prepared yet
well you know it's I'm working it like
it's ongoing I'm not gonna lie
you know I mean you you're in the shower
you working on speech am I gonna think
my mama first so I'm gonna take my agent
and Wyatt come first and who's gonna
come second and then you can't forget
nobody yeah eighth grade teachers gonna
be involved you know all that good no
you do what has been the reaction when
you're out and about and people have you
know have kind of resonated with math
has people come up to you and had any
fulfilling conversations or what's that
been like do they have you know what I
see now which has been different from
other roles you know before it was like
oh my gosh you're Hank from grim it's
way can I get a picture huh but now it's
really that
rounded thank you you know me I mean
honestly just for an example we were in
Chicago and my wife and I were walking
down the street and the bus driver honks
the horn there's a brother you know and
he just said and you just that was it I
said okay but you know to me and I knew
I knew that was what that was about what
that meant oh I love I love hearing that
he was an older gentleman you know you
can tell you said his 50s had a cool
little gray with the beard every single
ball here I said you know that subject
in pain for hours and whoever did this
is free and you worked with Regina King
in this one talk to me about just
soaking up the knowledge for each other
I feel like you both have some really
great advice to pass across the board
really I felt just an honor to be able
to look at her as a peer you know at
this point and so once we sort of I was
sort of able to get that sort of that
fan aspect out of the way it just became
two actors working together and I would
never forget we went out to dinner one
night and we're just talking about the
characters in the relationship and
whatnot and Regina looked at me and she
says brother we're gonna do this right
we're gonna we're gonna go in yes no no
we're going we we both I think raise the
bar for each other you guys were a
wonderful duo but I know you said that
was a really challenging role or one of
your most challenging roles a why plane
why was it playing a grieving father
that for you well again because you know
at the time you know my son at the time
was just getting ready to turn to but my
wife was also eight months pregnant with
our second child and so I really you
know you know bringing the baby to term
is just something that's you know it's
just scary
you know and so I think I was
internalizing that that said that fear
that in that anguish in an anxiety of
you know is my baby
you know gonna be okay you know and so I
was able to internalize that and use
that as part of the fear and the anguish
you have a degree as a grieving father
as well and so it just transported me to
a whole different place and it was you
know it was a dark place and and it
was great for that time and again things
don't just happen they happen just with
the holidays coming up I heard that you
would dress up as Santa Claus before can
you please describe you know your humble
beginning yeah absolutely you know when
I graduated college everybody else I you
know you looking for a hustle jobs yeah
and I always said to myself everybody a
lot of my friends were being waiters and
bartenders and I said I made a pact with
myself whatever job I'd do whatever
hustle job or you know job just to
sustain me it's gonna be a performance
yeah you know I'm an actor so I have to
perform and so I would I dressed up for
thanksgivin I dressed up as a pilgrim
now it was funny for that one of the the
anchors I'll never forget his gentleman
on Fox can't remember his name
but we were out at the Seaport and in
New York and he said hey ladies jedem we
have the pilgrims and here's pilgrim
Tyrone and so you know it was like a
couple my friend called me up said oh
you go from Tyrone I got a name and then
dressed up like you know like Santa
Claus during the you know the Christmas
holidays and it was were that time when
cell phones were just coming out so we
were working for Mike's print and you
know doing the cell phone jingles and
all that good stuff we did that for a
couple years
just like a teddy bear and I used to
also do telemarketing I used to do was I
would look at the region that I was
calling and different regions you know
east west south I would change you know
quietly yeah and so but the one that
always got in is sort of when you would
change it to an English accent or
something like that right so that's what
I would do I'll call up and say you know
hello my name is Russell who wants be
imported would love you'd have a survey
with me if you don't mind and they go oh
yeah there's no good in this moment I
know you were good at so tell me oh no
no really I must say it's just sort of
one of those things that come naturally
you know all those is performance just
to sort of help me get more comfortable
being in front of people comfortable
talking to people and that was always
just an entry entry way in and you do
that for a few years and you're you when
it's time to get on stage or do be a and
a movie setting or something like that
I'm ready you can turn it on yeah I'm
ready to let's go baby
okay
do you actually respond to telemarketers
now that you can tell you can see what
kind of number coming you know they got
slick too they go hey Russell what's up
this is Jimmy hey Jimmy what's up hey
man you always 15-dollar he won't do it
click
[Music]